but I know you just posted a story about
seeing alligator or feeling like you're
in a pond with crocodile was that
explained to me I had a dream where I
was with some YouTube celebrities and my
dad and my dog and it was just a very
odd dream I we were at some resort and
we were kind of kidding about like
alligators being everywhere and then all
of a sudden we're surrounded by these
huge alligators that look like they
could eat my dad whole and it was
terrifying and I don't really know what
it was from I say it was from maybe
losing someone and being scared of
losing someone else you know in that
dream I had almost lost him so it kind
of was pretty frightening when I woke up
how's he doing he's okay a the only
person who really like knew him like the
back of his hand with mom that's what
I'm worried about cuz I wanna be able to
be there for him like she was but I know
that I can't replace her
leaving I know you've been around your
dad for a long time you guys work
together how's he handling this how's
the family pull out the other well he's
definitely grieving you know but that's
understandable
you know everything that we see or do or
whatever reminds him a bath or whatever
or this this tea goes down memory lane
this time you know this is what Beth
would have done this is what she would
have said yesterday he told me when I
saw you driving in the car I thought it
was Beth coming screeches because that's
the only she's the only one who drives
like that type of thing so he said he
felt like Beth guided you to this
criminal yesterday I just happened I
just you know that they told us he was
wearing a black shirt black hat they
the first guy I came across was a
brother who looked just like him you
know but he had a white hat on so
immediately you know I couldn't run at
the time real good so I wasn't gonna cut
through the house so I went around the
site where I saw the back door of the
hole the whole thing and that's when I
saw the guy running and that's when I
said all he's running around back and
then everybody took off I couldn't
really catch up with nobody so I jumped
in the car I heard my dad say jump in
the car so I got in the car chased him
down and we ended up capturing him Beth
wrote beautiful no did your wife shared
with everybody would that mean to you to
see that and would it mean to her to
have that no really I thought it was you
know it was it was it was awesome to
Beth to do that you know what I mean
because at first you know it's not easy
getting into our family you know you can
say it sense and she wouldn't let you
know at least at least you know it
mended that that that gabber or wound or
whatever you want to call it and you
know couldn't she couldn't have done it
better your father started to mention it
but yes and it talks about and she talks
about in the post how there are hard
times and they had hard times but now in
the end that's you know it's uh
it's still hard to really put your
finger around you know what I mean it's
just hard to believe that she's even
gone you know so how are you doing
I'd say it hasn't really hit me yet but
you know walking around the house
getting ready for working so you know
senior stuff it's definitely you know
you think about it for a second in slate
you know maybe I don't want to move that
so she doesn't get mad then you know you
realize she's still right she's right
there with us in a sense and what's that
like I've lived out here for a year now
by myself and most of the time I'm like
oh what would what would mom think of if
I did this or if I did that and now it's
you know I feel like she can actually
see what I'm doing now rather than being
a figurative now it's I feel like it's
it's literal and that's it's been a lot
more like when I when I'm making
decisions it's a lot more like hard
hitting when I take her opinion anyone
mm-hmm but it was the thing that you
will take away from your mother and
what's the thing that you will miss the
most about her I'm definitely gonna take
away how determined and how passionate
she was I I started to see myself kind
of blossom into a mini Beth of you know
and I'm really glad that I could take
away her veracity and take just take so
much away from her and you know I feel
like I'm I'm so blessed to have her in
my life and you know she's not here
right now but I'm definitely gonna miss
her laugh that's something that when it
when he did come it was it was like
bells and it really made the whole
family happy
dog you said you're starting to see your
you're starting to see your wife and
yeah and your kids what are you seeing
well Gary if he's not gonna like this is
known as little Beth the spoiled is rut
right the one that she loved the most
her baby is right there
I once told Bonnie she was and a beef
with her mom and Beth was pretty strong
with potty and I said Bonnie came to me
and said dad she's being really mean to
me and she's being really nice to Gary
Gary he's her favorite and I said Bonnie
your real mother was killed in a car
accident when you were a little baby and
I said thanks that's not your real mom
she's like I knew something was wrong I
do it right well I don't know her so the
next Saturday Wilson first grade so the
next Saturday
I hear what the you mother mm-hmm
get in their grave Javid that's I went
in and she said what did you tell my
baby she was like crying and yelling at
me
can I go what if she's like you told I
was not a real mother and I go I see and
I started laughing and Beth started
laughing and then Bonnie said to mom mom
I saw pictures of me you know being
bored I knew that like you were I was
yours I was just making dad feel good
right so that has been something in her
family and we've always say of course we
know for sure Gary was ready but he has
the most I think characteristics about
him as mrs. mom did as far as mentally
not physically but mentally and you know
he's just turned 18 he's gonna be a cop
no question about it he's eating all
this cop stuff he freakin brings out on
bounties the rules and regulations
dad you've already broken three
misdemeanors we've only been out or two
hours you flickered your cigarettes out
the window littering any section six I'm
like shut up Beth so
he's the one that's like that and Leland
was her like hitman and finally a couple
years ago she goes you know what I love
Jamie Jamie and I go what did you just
say she goes I love Jamie she actually
loves Leland and so they started really
you know a she's the newest in the
family right right so we you know we
once I've seen her except that everybody
got to accept them and Jamie became a
really good friend of hers and you know
it's been a long time that they've been
friends longer they were just
acquaintances I don't think I've seen
her love and you want and else more than
Jamie yeah Leland knowing that and
knowing their bond as Jamie want to step
up and did she want to be more involved
now I think it was you know I think it
was devastating for Jamie just right at
the end when the relationship finally
took off is when it was over
you know what I mean so uh you know I
know that bothers her and so she she's
trying to step up and try and you know
but she's making friends with you know
rainy David's wife and get closer
relationships with Bonnie Lisa and
Cecily and things like that so that you
know she can be part of our family I
want to ask you two something if there's
one thing you would say to your mom what
would you tell her Jeremy let you go
first
probably that you know I appreciate like
how she raised me and it's made me the
man I am today one that wants to be a
cop the ones that knew I was compassion
for you know law enforcement
and she was my dad was like hell no
you're not being a cop when I first was
adamant about it but she was always like
accepting it and she gave me the you
know confidence to you know go be a
volunteer and you know do that kind of
stuff so I I appreciate that out of
everything that she didn't Bonnie what
would you say what would you tell her
I'm really appreciative to my mom for
everything she's ever done for me and
and I don't really know how to thank her
for it and I would tell her and thank
you thank you and I'm sorry I didn't go
to church with you every Sunday like you
wanted and sorry I didn't get to spend
all those moments with you that really
were supposed to be important and I took
those moments I took her for granted
did you but don't you think she's
looking down on you now and she sees the
woman that you're becoming I think she
does but I I want to be the best woman I
can for her
[Music]
you hear her say something like that I
mean that makes me emotional it's got to
make you emotional yeah just get that
over real quick and man up I hear oh now
she can see whatever Gary's doing it was
laying a better like mom please don't
judge me for how lazy I am sometimes I
was like oh my gosh she's probably
seeing what I'm doing and it's like what
are you doing he's laying in bed
watching TV do you talk to her all the
time I found myself actually talking to
her a lot um I had a particularly
emotional night last night I started
watching videos and one of them was when
we were at the Kahala mandarins when
with dolphin mm-hm
and I don't I don't watch the show a lot
because you know I feel like it's
moments I'm not a part of but I'd like
to see their job but uh there is a
moment where she started screaming my
name she's like Bonnie Giovanni Joe and
that made me cry so much of she's
knowing that I won't hear you say Bonnie
she won't say my name again it's it's so
it's so different and I'm gonna miss her
voice a lot even when she's yelling I'll
still miss it
Lillian will you think about her when
you're out there and will you miss her
yelling I know that you guys sometimes I
already have I've already noticed the
difference we've all had been out for
one day and you know I was thinking to
myself man if Beth was here she would be
on come on let's go already
tell her my dad shut up you talk too
much let's go you know what I mean by
the time you get there this guy's gonna
be in Mexico so definitely definitely
it's there's definitely a different
aspect around
you know but uh you know I think we'll
pull through more strong family and it's
terrible that we had to go through that
but like I said I know I know
our bond is strong and and we work
together which makes it even stronger
you know and I believe that Beth rent
such a tight ship and that you know it
just became when you do something over
and over and over again it's just
rhetorical it just becomes natural you
know and I think that that's already
instilled in all of us and that you know
that's why it works so well is because
of all the years of grinding on this you
know what I mean do that you know and
now you know you got the finished
product I know this sounds crazy but do
you think in the end the Beth is gonna
because this family could be a little
dysfunctional with that do you think of
the edge she's fixing your dysfunctional
family she better not I used to say okay
you know I said honey what is
dysfunctional me which is like that's
you baby does have meat she's like
you're not do you don't do things normal
I thought well then normal people never
get noticed and I want to be I want to
since I was five years old I've been a
legend in my own mind and she goes do
you just keep being dysfunctional I'll
try to fix it right it was like a bad
word to her it was it to me because I
really you know like that's oh well you
want to see some dysfunctional people
follow us or elbow Meg you'll see some
of our clients
that's dysfunctional was there a note or
anything that your mom left you oh I
know is I was left make up in clothes
which I am completely fine with cuz she
had amazing sense of style and Jerry I
mean she's already given enough to me I
think one Gary when she was before she
passed away she done gave Gary
everything you know make sure he had a
car make sure it's you know look at his
truck outside you know what I mean he
didn't buy that yes I did what I have so
honey he saw this a white truck uh-huh
finally gave him a little bit nice word
of God he put it in his name finances
himself but that's a very good point was
what she prepared everybody yep she left
us with a great foundation hmm and
that's something that we won't forget
[Music]
you